[Musique]
la vie comme vous savez est certainement
le plus beau présent que l'on puisse
recevoir mais c'est pas toujours un
cadeau et très vite j'ai dû m'en rendre
compte
pour avoir beaucoup de problèmes
d'élocution je ne pouvais pas parler
comme tout le monde je parlais plus tôt
avec un char est bien est-ce qu'elle
était guère facile une anecdote alors
que j'étais tout petit jeu réclamé à cor
et à cri comme font les enfants à
sagelat qui tiennent à recevoir quelque
chose un caillou un caillou ma pauvre
mère essaie de faire preuve
d'imagination
pensant un trio cher chose que je
pouvais bien vouloir et chaque fois je
finissais par faire comme ceux ci et
part pleurnicher parce qu'on ne me
comprenait pas et je voulais toujours à
cailhau la voisine ayant peut-être plus
d'expérience interpellé pain mais
pleurnicheries fini par venir dire mais
qu'est ce qui arriva josiane et maman de
répondre les bras au ciel
je ne sais pas j'ai tout essayé je ne
vois pas ce qu'elle veut elle veut à
cailhau et à part ça rien d'autre et je
ne sais pas quoi lui donner je ne la
comprends pas et cette dame
par expérience les bagues demande
d'aller chercher alors puisque je n'ai
pas très grande
j'ai poussé un tabouret je me suis hissé
dessus et sur la pointe des pieds
j'ai pu prendre une orange vous rendez
compte une orange sur le buffet ce que
pour maman était effarant je crois
qu'elle aurait pu la faire avaler qu'il
était impatient d'aider mais qu'est ce
qu'elle veut vous rendez compte un
camion pour une orange
à quel point j'étais en difficulté mais
le pire devait arriver car la première
année scolaire
quelle époque se faisait à 6 en garde
dès que j'ouvrais la bouche tout le
monde se moquait de moi et vous savez
que les enfants sont pas toujours des
trains entre sont pas tendres et vous
ridiculisez se moque de vous alors du
coup je me suis retrouvé à chaque
récréation
ben porte un bonnet d'âne parce que
c'était comme ça et qu'on pouvait pas
faire autrement à l'époque je n'ai aucun
regret sur ce point
la preuve je suis là mais ce qui est
certain c'est que cela désespéré mes
parents et ses films l'instant mon père
décida de se mettre en route
et chaque soir dans cette cuisine que je
n'oublierai jamais il me prenait à part
car j'ai deux frères et il était sur ma
droite il y avait encore la lampe à
pétrole à l'époque pour nous et cette
lampe à pétrole a chanté l es10 histoire
un petit peu jaune il ya venez courir
sous ce livre de lecture
tu étais toujours du charabia nemdil et
tu dois bien avoir une solution
il doit bien faire quelque chose pour
connecter ton cerveau infecte au langage
il refuser sous d'amour était plus grand
que tout et il refusait il voulait que
je parle comme tout le monde même si je
pouvais pas aller plus loin alors
immobiliers tout simplement à lire à
haute voix en me disant que je devais
utiliser trois de mes sens la vue le
toucher et l'ouïe et qu'il est bien une
de ces trois qui resterait en moi qui
trouverait quelque part le moyen de se
fixer
et voilà comment avec mon index
il m'a appris à lire chaque soir je peux
vous dire que des fois j'étais épuisée
et kohl's et papa je veux dormir
il faisait non josiane il faut que tu
parles faux cul pas correctement
moi aussi je me lever demain matin 5
heures mais je veux tu parles et dans
ses yeux il y avait tout l'amour que
peut-être du désespoir
alors je relisais et voyez ce n'était
pas difficile
un toit pour me montrer le chemin de la
lecture
j'aimerais que le mémoriser parce que
vous pour aider d'autres personnes ou
d'autres enfants avec la même difficulté
que moi tu as mon pauvre père c'est un
instant il a des succès la pathologie
qui me tenait
malheureusement au coeur et au corps et
au langage était la dyslexie et vient
peut-être qu'il aurait été plus rassuré
son enfant un problème il y avait des
mots à mettre dessus alors je devais
lire avec le doigt et je me permets de
vous lire une citation qui n'est pas
noir je vous rassure pour que vous
puissiez voir comment je vais me prendre
c'était ainsi tout homme qui dirige qui
fait quelque chose a contre lui
ceux qui voudraient
faire la même chose ce qu'il faut
précisément le contraire et surtout la
grande armée de gens beaucoup plus
sévères qui ne font rien et c'est signé
clarity les années sont passées et un
jour pour mon travail je vais passer une
médecine donc une tout simplement chez
le médecin pour faire un contrôle vers
un médecin
et voilà que ce médecin quand je suis
rentré il va de soi que avec une telle
difficulté de langage plus nul que moi
l'orthographe et tout ce qui va avec
y'avait pas j'étais vraiment une
championne de ce côté là et bien croyez
le lorsque je suis rentré chez ce
médecin j'ai pas fait deux mètres il va
montrer du doigt ce fameux texte qui met
des mais même en train de vous vous êtes
retenu le dr graf
effectivement j'étais nul en orthographe
pourtant aujourd'hui je suis écrivain
comme quoi tout peut arriver mais moi je
me suis dit comme il a pu le faire comme
l'a pu le voir
j'aime à penser peut-être qu'elle met
chef avait dit que j'avais des grosses
difficultés et je suis presque rentré
dans ma coquille puis non il semblerait
que nous ne marchons pas comme tout le
monde je m'observe souvent jean pas
encore trouvé comment je marchais et je
pense que ça ne se voit pas mais la
ville de ses filles qui étaient
dyslexiques
il s'était vraiment posé sur le problème
maintenant d'en parler j'ai expliqué mon
père ce qu'il avait fait ce qui l'avait
pas fait il m'a dit leur faudra le
remercier parce que je n'ai pas été
capable je me suis précipité en partant
du travail pour le voir mes parents ils
étaient côte à côte sur le divan parce
que papa était paralysée et j veu pa
page est remercié au nom d'un médecin
pour m'avoir appris à lire et puis bien
fait mais ça va pas maman m'a regardé
comme si j'étais né sera terrestre en
dur mais papa n'a jamais pu apprendre à
lire il sait ni lire écrire à peine lire
et écrire
je n'ai rien dit je me suis éloigné ne
comprenant pas et puis j'ai compris que
l'amour pouvait dépasser tous exactement
le soir on se couchant il était inquiet
il ya travers le songe qui peut tout
ouvrir les portes de l'irréel delà du
réel
on sait pas où ça s'arrête il
m'apprenait à lire et c'est pour ça
qu'il a eu des clés et c'est pour ça que
je suis là aujourd'hui
alors vous savez si vous aujourd'hui
vous avez un handicap quel qu'il soit
mais surtout un handicap
concernant la lecture ou un de vos
enfants quand quelqu'un dit lui de
prendre soin l'index
parler à haute voix ne laissez pas dans
la difficulté de ne pas pouvoir lire
parce que c'est trop important
donc allez-y ouvrez les portes je vous
assure c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire aujourd'hui quoi qu'on
fasse
vous n'avez qu'à regarder autour de vous
il vous faut toujours lire le mode
d'emploi
comment le lire je ne sais pas lire ce
ne peut pas lire alors permettez à tout
le monde de lire et je peux vous dire
car là vous rendrez service à tout le
monde et peut-être une aventure
extraordinaire s'ouvrira devant tu vous
savez c'est important pour chacun
d'entre nous aujourd'hui je suis là
parfois quand je suis un peu trop émotif
il ya des mots qui part dans tous les
sens mais quelle importance
j'arrive à faire ce que je veux et c'est
magnifique alors peut-être que parmi
vous effectivement des gens elle indique
à quel qu'il soit alors je vais vous
lire une citation que j'aime beaucoup
qui est un peu comme des cannes que je
garde ces deux citations pour moi et
cette situation devrait vous aider
elle n'est toujours pas de moi et cette
fois je prends pas mon index foyer ce
n'est pas parce que les choses sont
difficiles que nous n'osons pas c'est
parce que nous n'osons pas qu'elles sont
difficiles et c'est signé sénèque
alors si aujourd'hui quel que soit votre
handicap parce qu'il ya pas que la
dyslexie et on les voit pas touche
et bien osé et s'il vous plaît mettez
vous en route
c'est le plus beau cadeau que vous
puissiez vous faire